في اول ظهور له منذ اعتقاله
عنصر الحرس الوطني المتهم بتسريب معلومات
سريه امام قادم فيدرالي في مدينه بوسطن
وجهت له تهمه الاولى حفظ ونشر دون اذن
المعلومات مرتبطه بالامن القومي والثانيه
ازاله وحفظ دون اذن وثائق سريه ديشار
البالغ من العمر واحد وعشرين عاما
ظهر في المحكمه مكبلا بالاصفاظ برفقه محام
عينه المحكمه وبحضور والديه اللذين لم
يجيبا على اسئله الصحفيين المتجمعين خارج
المحكمه
سيتم اتهام جاكي شيرا بموجب قانون التجسس
والذي يقضي بشكل اساسي ان المستندات
السريه اذا اخذت بشكل خاطئ او اذا فقدت او
سلمت او احتفظ بها فهي جريمه فيدراليه
بموجب قانون التجسس
الشكوى الجنائيه التي نشرت تزامنا مع
اتهام دشاره تميت اللثام عن تفاصيل باتت
معروفه بشان تسريبه معلومات ووثائق سريه
عبر مجموعه تواصل على منصه ديسكورد كما
تكشف عن انه حاول بعد الكشف عن التسريبات
البحث في سجلات سريه عما اذا كانت عرفت
هويته في المحكمه اخبر ديشيرا انه قد
يواجه في حال الادانه عقوبه تبلغ 15 عاما
بالسجن بينما تستمر في واشنطن تفاعلات هذه
القضيه التي وضعت الاداره الامريكيه في
موقف محرج مع الحلفاء قبل الخصوم وزير
العدل الامريكي بدوره شدد على ان وزاره
الدفاع تقود جهدا لتقييم ومراجعه تداعيات
التسريبات على الامن القومي
حاليا جهدا مهما لتقييم ومراجعه تداعيات
الامن القومي بالاضافه الى اجراء مراجعه
لاساليب الوصول الى المعلومات والمحاسبه
واجراءات الرقابه التي تتبعها الوزاره حتى
لا يحدث امر مشابه مره اخرى
وفي وقت اثنى فيه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن على الاجراء السريع الذي اتخذته جهه
انفاذ القانون للتحقيق والرد على تسريب
الوثائق تواجه ادارته اسئله من المشرعين
تتعلق بحيثيات ما حدث وعدم رصد التسريبات
قبل فوات الاوان بسبب